max kaiser and this is the kaiser report
i'm here with stacy herbert and this
is summer solutions every year we try to
dig into the
solutions and we've got a special guest
today
jim kunstler of counselor.com stacy
right
remember james was a guest on our series
front running
so at that time we were looking at all
the radical platforms
of the various candidates for the
democratic
presidential nomination and they were
radical things like ubi
mmt and all sorts of other ideas well
they've all become basically law now we
all have them
implemented so we're going to talk to
him about a few of these but jim
welcome to summer solutions pleasure to
be with you both
will the money printing continue until
morale improves and
just how much more can morale improve
anyway like stock markets are at
all-time highs housing prices soaring
well wages are at all-time highs so like
how much more money printing are we
going to endure a happy happy happy
is america now it kind of depends on how
worthless the money becomes as the
punishments of money printing continue
and i think we can
probably all agree that there's a great
hazard
in printing no end of money with
quotation marks around it
because it's becoming increasingly
detached from any real
productive activity in the on
on the ground economy i remember back
during the
time of fdr there
was a lot of money printing going on but
there was also a big works program so
people were out there working and
building and infrastructure
and bridges and roads but this time
they're just printing in money and
giving it to folks
and they're not expecting anything in
return and
we're getting a lot of inflation but
we're not getting anything done
jim let's remember that even back during
the 1930s in the great depression
that notwithstanding uh the high rates
of unemployment
we still had a great deal of productive
infrastructure
and we were still in fact producing a
great deal of
value and goods and things of of worth
um and you know what we what we had
could still be
classified as something like real
industrial growth
the problem that we have now especially
with the shenanigans of the central
banks
is that we are entering a period of
history of uh
of non-growth and the reversal of growth
and if you don't have that thing called
growth you don't
you don't produce enough surplus wealth
to service
the debts that you're piling up and now
that we're piling up the debts at a kind
of astronomical
hockey stick uh uh a path
we're we're guaranteeing that we're
going to have a debt system
in which there's no expectation that
debt ever gets paid back
which is not a credible debt system and
that's
kind of the hinge of the problem so
we're kind of going through a period as
well
of deglobalization or certainly tensions
between
the rising power and the declining power
and the declining power of the united
states and everybody else
essentially including europe so it will
that be
a solution in a way to the problem
with especially the rust belt and all of
the
the people who hillary declared were
deplorables people who used to have jobs
and
and manufactured wealth and had great
jobs and
stuff like that like will that be a
solution for them
solution is a bit of a tricky word uh
because
we must remember that reality has
mandates of its own
reality compels us to have to endure
certain conditions uh one of the
conditions that we're being asked to
endure now
is the withering and and reorganizing of
uh
uh international trade you could call
that the global economy
you know where there's going to continue
to be exchanges between nations
but uh you know the power differentials
are going to change
not just in in the ability to project
force but the ability to project
economic
domination and power and that's now
changing a great deal and i think the
bottom line is that
for the west the uh world is going to
become a bigger place again
rather than a small the smaller place
that uh
you know when tom friedman published the
lexus and the olive tree
he made the point that globalism was
going to become a permanent installation
of the human condition
and that's proving not to be exactly
true and now that it's withering you
know we are facing a new disposition of
things
including basically a lower
standard of living for the western
advanced economies
and and probably in the united states
considerably lower than than what we've
been used to
and we're trying desperately to
compensate for that
by printing all this money to pay for
the stuff
to pay for the standard of living we
have now which is actually uh leaving us
behind
the ability to add value in a
manufacturing economy and very
export-led economies shrinks what it
sounds like you're saying there and so
global standards
of living deteriorate as everything
becomes kind of commodified
uh and there is no um i guess david
ricardo's
sense of competitive advantage
amongst nations it just becomes one big
global
commodified goo commodified musical
chairs maybe
you know where where uh uh we're
constantly shifting
around in the in the the circle of uh
futility trying to keep ahead of
everybody else
when in fact the general pool of what's
available
is shrinking and and the most crucial
part of that is the energy pool
and you know we've discussed this before
i'm kind of uh
i regard the the energy inputs to the
economy
as being central and crucial and
we're facing the situation now you know
the the shale oil miracle which was
supporting american energy production
at a very high level was already being
challenged before
covet 19 hit and the main problem with
the shale oil miracle was that
they spent 10 years jacking up
production of oil
to a tremendous level much higher than
the previous 1970 peak
but at the same time they were proving
that they couldn't make any money doing
it
and so they had gotten all this
tremendous amount of investment
uh in the 10 years after the 2009 great
financial
emergency and now that they've
demonstrated that they can't make money
producing all the shale oil
they can't get additional investment to
continue those operations
which have to be continually you know
re-upped and re-up because this is a
resource that depletes so rapidly
you know the average shale oil well
loses 60
of its mojo after the first year and is
generally out of business after four
years
so they have to constantly redrill and
refract these are tremendously costly
operations
you know the old oil cost four hundred
thousand dollars in today's money
to drill an oil well and it was like a
cash register that ran for 30 years
the shale wells you know cost between
six and 12 million dollars per well to
drill
and they're you know they they start
crapping out after the first
year at 60 of the loss
so um you know it it's unfortunately
a loser game and uh we got a lot of uh
kind of we it allowed us to postpone our
problems our reckonings with
with energy but now that's over and
you know it's coincided with the the
terrible destruction of the covid19
uh you know the reaction to the virus
and uh it's placed us in a great deal
apparel
the absurdity of fracking as you said it
kept on losing money and our pointing it
out of course
saw us our program be mentioned and the
whole director of national intelligence
was saying that was somehow us saying
that somehow caused hillary to lose
the election in 2016. but nevertheless
it was it was possible because of
zero percent interest rates it was
possible because of the exorbitant
privilege
of the us dollar so
james tell me the
u.s dollar turns 50 in august
as we know it the the all fiat global
reserve standard
no backing by gold no need to send our
gold overseas
due to our huge trade deficit does it
survive
much longer how much longer can this
live is are we going to
the the elite enjoy the exorbitant
privilege but the majority
seem not to have any sort of privilege
off of this
at all the financial economy has been
detaching from the real on the ground
economy during that whole period
and it's become exp it's become
especially extreme
uh over the last few years really the
last 10 years since uh
we since the central bank started
messing around with exorbitant money
creation from nowhere um
and uh you know it it now that the uh
the the amount of creation has become uh
just
uh out of this world you know going from
uh
uh deficits uh annual deficits of
less than a trillion dollars a year to
now something like
you know i think where the the us budget
is like 10 trillion dollars this year
including all of the
you know the various rescue plans of
this kind and that kind
uh 10 trillion dollars a year out of
nowhere where you just can't match that
with
the production of real wealth that means
that your uh
you know your financial system is
completely abstracted
from real economic activity and that
tends to suggest that you're going to
harm your currency so i i would be uh
uh of the group that that believes that
the currency is going to be
uh damaged sooner rather than later and
i you know look we're seeing it already
in the
the price of cars i think the average
price of a car is over 30 000
now just in the last year you know you
go to the supermarket
there's not a single item that's under
four dollars you know including a jar of
peanut butter
and uh you know we're seeing it but um
you know the old uh saying goes there's
two ways of going broke
you can have no money or you can have
plenty of money that's not worth
anything and we seem to
be choosing that you know the second one
because it's easier
for the authorities to get away with
that and by the way
you know the whole modern monetary
theory that
this exorbitant money printing and
spending and fiscal
spending is based on you know it
represents kind of the final
uh horizon of detachment from from being
real
from having a real economy i don't think
we're going to get beyond
mmt all right that's incredible uh we're
going to pick this up
in part two with jim cunsler
don't go away
welcome back to the kaiser report with
max kaiser stacy herbert and james
howard kunstler going to pick up where
we left off
in our summer solutions conversation
with james
james it seems that all this money
printing now
really it's taking on a different
character you know
people aren't really expecting there to
be genuine growth
it feels more like palliative care in a
hospice
i feel as though america's become a
giant hospice
and the money printing is to ease our
pain as we
essentially commit financial suicide
that's a very good way of putting it
and nobody else has put it that way very
interesting
uh you know if you really want to talk
about solutions
uh i think that the best way to go with
that is probably
for americans to somehow wrap their
minds around
uh the following dynamic you know it's
not that complicated
uh reality is sending us this message
about uh you know what kind of
conditions were
uh we're gonna be meeting of uh you know
resource scarcity and
capital scarcity and
the real message is to get smaller to
get more local
uh to downscale the gigantism of the
things that we do
you know for example we you know we've
got a nation that is now relying almost
solely
on super duper giant corporations to
deliver
goods that are you know made 12 000
miles away
uh if you really want to have an economy
you've got to employ people where you
live
you know also along with that
you've got to have people who occupy not
only economic but social niches in your
community so that they play different
roles in your community
so you actually have a society that has
some dimension to it
not just a society of consumers who are
like pac-men
you know going across the board uh you
know gobbling up
cheese doodles so to rebuild that kind
of
economy is going to be a tremendous task
i think we're going to be forced into it
by necessity whether we like it or not
you know we're going to be dragged
kicking and screaming
into rebuilding our local economies
making something
even if it even if it ends up occurring
at a lower
kind of standard of living than what
we're used to because
you know the human project has to go on
including the american version of it
and uh this is gonna be quite an
emergency that we're gonna have to uh
really put our shoulders to the wheel
through
and and somehow uh bull our way through
i have a question about that because can
we get there from here
because it seems like we would need a
civil
society as well we would need to have
adult conversations
between these various tribes in america
it does seem like i mean i've never seen
it like this before
sure there were problems in the 60s and
70s but it was like the people against
the government
essentially and now it's like the
government with one
set of people the elites the cable news
hosts and
think tankers against the deplorables
so how can you ever even want to bring
how can we get to the point where they
bring manufacturing or wealth creation
or
or hiring local if if you
think most americans are deplorable and
that they're white supremacists and
and horrible people so how do we get to
the point where we want to help them
i think you're describing what i would
call the woke hysteria
which has become a tremendous
interruption in our history and in our
national life
and uh i would look at it this way that
you know when you're in a
an economy and a society that is under
tremendous stress
and is generating a huge amount of
anxiety
uh and uncertainty uh you're gonna
the the society is gonna respond by
doing crazy things
and uh this happens in history you know
there we have the
medieval hysterias and you know we have
all kinds of
uh uh tremendous social uh
upsets when when things like this happen
so
uh you know we're just gonna have to
probably wait it out i think that the
uh it's a lot it's liable to kind of
solve itself
because hysterias tend to burn
themselves out
this one has quite a resemblance to the
jacobin rebellion
in the latter stages of the french
revolution where the jacobins come along
in 1793
and they're really quite crazy this is
robespierre and sanjustin
and that whole gang and they start to
impose all these crazy new social
conditions on the population they say
you know you're not going to have the
catholic church anymore we're going to
have the worship of the great spiritual
being
yeah you're not going to have a seven
day week anymore you're going to have a
10-day week
we're going to change all the names of
the months of the year
and this went on for about a period of
11 months and finally the french people
just turned around and said wow we've
had enough of this
you know you guys are out of here and
they cut off robespierre's head
and that was the end of the jack bennism
and you know the world didn't hear about
them again you know
after that that was it well you know
different versions of them sort of
rebounded and came back in in the in the
form of let's say the
the leninists in 1917 and the nazis you
know and
but periodically you get these hysterias
and they're a product of this tremendous
anxiety
that is caused by uh a culture that
seems and fears that it's going to
lose uh so much uh stuff of value to
them
including you know their their their
whole way of life their their daily
routines
um their ability to pay for uh
their shelter and their food and these
are very crucial things
and the kovid 19 emergency actually
ruined a lot of households and uh you
know i suppose that that's
uh causing just a tremendous amount of
pain and suffering out there
and uh a lot of those aren't the
wokesters because the welksters tend to
be the people
who are doing better you know and they
want to teach us all tend
tendentious moral lessons about how to
live right
and uh you know it's becoming extremely
tedious i've lost a lot of friends over
this and you know i hear that other
people have too and
so i i don't think that sentiment has
been more divided in this country since
the civil war
i hope it doesn't get to that you know
the bottom line of what we're talking
about now
is simply this is under these conditions
expect a lot of disorder you know of one
kind or another whether it's
financial disorder you know the bottom
falling out of the dollar
or social disorder riots and looting or
intellectual disorder you know being
asked to believe
things that are palpably untrue uh
or uh you know even disorder in science
or the science as we're calling it
lately where
you know uh the scientific authorities
present
ideas as being truthful and we find out
nine months later that they're not
and that's a terrible blow to the you
know to the intellectual life of the
country so
a lot of disorder and i think that
people discount that and don't pay
sufficient attention
to the potential for that what you're
describing there is
you know a breakdown of institutions
right education
religious social institutions
i guess because in the last 30 or 40
years every bright spark in the box has
gravitated to
wall street right people don't go into
education anymore they become quants at
a hedge fund
people don't believe in god anymore they
believe in wall street is america's
uh vatican uh we we pray to uh
the likes of jamie dimon as our god so
we have no
underlying fundamental institutions
anymore we only have
greed the problem with everybody uh you
know with half a brain
trying to go to wall street to make a
gazillion dollars
is it it represents essentially uh
racketeering
which is uh racketeering is defined as
you know making money dishonestly
and unfortunately that's that's uh now
infected
all of these institutions and and uh
ironically
two of the worst places that it's
infected are education
and medicine and you know both of them
have
uh very uh they are um fields of uh
or sectors of our daily life that have
very high
ideals and aspirations you know in
medicine
the whole point is to do no harm
and in education the idea is to search
for the truth
and we've got racketeering going on in
medicine that's so bad that nobody wants
to really go to the hospital anymore
because they know they're going to come
out bankrupt if not harmed even further
medically
and the colleges are now doing two kinds
of racketeering
they're they're racketeering the college
loan system
and they're they're engaging in
intellectual racketeering
by uh presenting fields of study that
are unreal
and uh uh that that are uh you know
religious uh
um fantasias
so uh you know they've both rendered
themselves
uh to be failures and and you can't have
this kind of
intense failure institutional failure in
a culture
and hope to survive intact well we're
also kind of like idiocracy heading
towards idiocracy
at a time when as you mentioned like a
lot of these
institutions are collapsing our economy
is we're being out-competed
we're like getting rid of like states
like california getting rid of advanced
math
because they're um it was like they said
white supremacy even though most of the
students were actually
asian who were getting into the advanced
uh math
classes things like that like it just
doesn't make any sense but the whole
racketeering as well
like in this new infrastructure bill or
maybe it's in the six trillion dollar
budget who knows
but in there there's something like
between 50 and 100 billion
none of it's ever transparent or open or
discussed but
there's like a hundred billion to build
uh
for the chip manufacturers to build
semiconductor chips
you know the bottom line of racketeering
is that it's simply dishonest
yes and when you have and so what we're
seeing is that a society that is
absolutely
pervasively dishonest that can't tell
itself an honest story
you know that can't discharge real
justice that can't uh
ex that never accepts any consequences
for the things that it does
and that's just extremely dangerous but
i must say in the case of medicine
and education the solutions are there
but they're a little
unappetizing because once again they're
going to be mandated by reality
not not not by our wishes and our
preferences
and and the way that'll shake out is
this the system of higher education is
going to collapse
you know a lot of colleges are going to
go out of business and universities are
going to downsize
drastically even the state universities
and in medicine
you're going to see the complete
collapse of the you know amalgamated
hospital insurance rackets and that's
going to devolve by necessity into local
clinical care
that's what i'm saying with these
semiconductor chips is
health care is a racket and therefore
the government ends up
spending paying for medicare medicaid
they have to pay for it all because
nobody could afford it
the same thing with education okay
nobody could afford tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of dollars of debt
trillions over the whole population they
want to wipe those debts out because
nobody could pay them
the same thing with the semiconductor
chips is like intel spent a hundred
billion dollars on share buybacks
instead of innovation and building
factories they turned down steve jobs
when he came to them with the iphone
so it's a total racket and what's going
to happen instead well the government
the taxpayer has to come forward again
to bail out the semiconductor chip thing
because our whole structure
everything is a lie as you say well yeah
and you know one of the main ideas in my
long emergency book
that came out a while ago quite a while
ago was
the idea that as this long emergency
gained traction
uh one of the manifestations would be
that uh
the federal government would become
increasingly ineffectual
and and impotent and unable to discharge
its obligations or fulfill its promises
and i think
we're seeing that climax now in the
extravagant promises
of you know giving billions of dollars
to keep existing rackets going that are
already
you know dishonest that aren't really
working for example the one you you just
mentioned about education you know
they they seek to wipe clean the college
debt
slate right but why so they can continue
a new round of debt and a new round of
you know running education
exactly the same way you know reality is
that we're not going to keep
most of these rackets or maybe any of
these rackets going
you know we're going to have to
rearrange daily life and the activities
of daily life
and uh the the we're gonna have to
reconstruct real communities
and it's gonna be very hard it's gonna
be attended by a certain amount of
disorder
and we're just gonna have to grit our
teeth and get through it wow blistering
jim counselor of consular.com thanks for
being on summer solutions
a pleasure to be with you both all right
and that's going to do it for this
edition of max keiser and stacey herbert
kaiser reports summer solutions thanks
to special guest jim counselor of
consular.com until next time
bye y'all
you